hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update during pax east this weekend
the Bioware developers dropped a couple
hints about the next Mass Effect game
while Bioware was tight-lipped about any
details regarding the setting or story
of the upcoming Mass Effect game we did
get some interesting information from
writer Kathleen roots art and art
director Joel McMillan when asked by a
fan what platforms Bioware was
considering running their next game on
McMillan said it's kind of tricky to
officially comment on that but I mean
Jen for being Xbox one and PlayStation 4
looks pretty awesome and mass effects an
awesome looking game when asked by
another fan if the next Mass Effect will
allow for same-sex and interspecies
relationships roots art said we can't
divulge that but I'll just say that
inclusivity is part of the Bioware
mandate so we did our best Bioware
announced the next Mass Effect game back
in September 2012 promising it will
deliver a fresh and new experience and
won't feature a commander shepard but
that's all we know regarding the story
so far when we have new details on the
next Mass Effect game you'll be able to
read them right here on gamespot com